hello everyone and welcome to the game I
promised in the previous video it's a
game from yesterday's division three of
the chessel Masters Daniel Duo versus
Min Le a Vietnamese Grand Master Min Le
and um okay in in class CH duo with some
200 rating points higher rated than Min
Le but in Rapid uh as m is is a speed
chess specialist he he plays a lot of
bullet a lot of Blitz um it's uh it's
not that great of a gap uh however yeah
you you've seen in previous couple
videos uh how we plays and he's just an
incredible attacker he creates always
creates something out of nothing uh but
there is another amongst the the 2700
players and that is Daniel Duo sometimes
okay maybe rard rort and okay Leon but
Leon is pretty much an allaround player
he can play anything but if you if you
really had to pick the top three
attackers they would be way Daniel lubov
and um rard rort uh so let's check out
this game and why it's so incredible and
uh the pause the video moment I'm sure
you guys will really appreciate as it's
uh it's something really really
beautiful uh sorry if you if you hear
some drilling you know I have some some
stuff being done here uh so let's check
it out danil with the white pieces opens
with Pawn to G3 he starts with the sort
of the king fan opening uh D5 and now
Bishop to G2 we have Knight to F6 and
now Knight to F3 so I'm going for well
sort of an Indian setup we have Knight
beat to D7 uh and now castles we have
Pawn to E5 grabbing the full Center and
pawn to D3 stopping E4 for the moment
Pawn to C6 and now uh the game has been
reached before it's been played in a lot
of grandmas games but the move Daniel
plays is a new one and it is now as of
move six that we have a completely new
game so okay he wants to stop further
advancement of the pawn plays Pawn to A5
also stops Pawn to B4 Knight to C3 and
now Bishop to B4 okay just nicely
developing we have Pawn to E4 uh D
captures an E4 we have Knight captures
on e4 and now Castle King side we have
Bishop to G5 pinning the Knight on F6
and um well the problem with H6 here is
that you can just capture and weaken D5
Pawn for example now Knight will have to
capture you're going to capture on E5
and you're going to be up a pawn and the
after Knight captures white can decide
whether to capture with the D Pawn or
with um the bishop on G2 so instead
Bishop to E7 was played and now Knight
captures on F6 we have Bishop captures
Bishop captures Queen captures and just
Rook to E1 so okay nothing um
spectacular Happening Here putting more
pressure on the E on the E Pawn and me
advances it to E4 uh he wants to give up
this Pawn that will probably remain a
target for for the rest of the game uh
to capture the pawn on B2 uh so Knight
to D2 Daniel invites the capture on D3
uh which meanly goes for E captures on
D3 and now Knight to E4 attacking the
queen and just Queen captures on B2 okay
we have Queen captures on D3 and now
Knight to E5 so uh here okay danil
sacrificed the pawn but he's up in
development however after Knight to E5
and the attack on Daniel's Queen okay
the bishop is coming into the game black
will soon equalize in development and he
will be able to enjoy his extra Pawn or
or that is the plan so Queen to D6
putting pressure on the Knight but it's
still fine the queen is defending it but
what if the Rook attacks the queen where
is the queen going you can't go to C3
you can't go to D4 uh that's going to be
a free piece so Knight back to C4
quickly attacking dub of's queen queen
to C5 and now Queen to B4 mean Ls up a
pawn he wants to trade queens and enjoy
his extra material but uh danil says
Nope not so fast Queen to H5 and already
you have to wonder okay if Knight comes
to G5 do I kick it away with H6 then
should I play H6 and prevent Knight to
G5 all together and the engine says yeah
you should play H6 and white has nothing
and that's exactly what me plays
and they still both have enough time
they started with 10 minutes on the
clock duu has eight minutes here and the
ml has six minutes on the clock Daniel
plays Pawn to C3 it's a very nice move
because uh objectively might not be
doing all that much but it forces um me
let to waste time does you go Queen B3
Queen B2 Queen to B6 Queen to E7 uh
probably not Queen to E7 you know in
front of the white Rook but you have to
calculate other options so Queen to B6
was played and here we reach the
position where I really want you to
pause the video and try to find the
absolute best move for danil uh while I
give you a couple of
seconds so uh for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations on being a
true Master attacker and for those of
you who just want to enjoy the show it
is Bishop the F1 this is the the prized
move and to give you an idea of why
Bishop to F1 is so strong uh well daniil
of course wants to play play Knight to
F6 with check just by knowing that it's
danil wielding the white pieces you know
that Knight to F6 has to be played uh
however here it doesn't work uh just yet
because if G captures after Rook to E4
there's no Rook to G4 the bishop covers
the G4 square and now best you can do is
play something like Queen captures on H6
and after Queen to C5 preparing to trade
off Queens uh you can play Bishop to E4
threaten Checkmate but there's Bishop to
F5 and that's sort of the problem Queen
captures on F6 You'll Play Bishop to G6
and white will have nothing more than a
Perpetual here after Queen H6 King G8
Queen to G6 and so on and so on however
after Queen to B6 and Bishop to F1 there
is a huge problem here how do you defend
the Knight the Knight cannot go to D6
the Knight covers that the Knight cannot
go to E5 the queen covers that you
cannot go to E3 the pawn covers that
there's a pawn here there's a queen here
and all the other squares are uh covered
you can play Knight to B2 Rook a to B1
we will take care of that and if you try
well what else is there to try you could
defend the Knight with Queen to B3 but
then Knight to C5 attacks the queen
takes away all of the squares for the
queen and next move you just lose a
knight so that's the problem so the only
way to defend the Knight after Bishop to
F1 uh is to play Bishop to E6 and what
was the one thing preventing you from
sacrificing the Knight on F6 the bishop
on C8 guarding the G4 square and now
danal just plays Bishop captures on C4
and now the bishop has to move from the
defense of the G4 Square otherwise
you're just going to be down a piece so
Bishop captures on C4 and now dubov goes
for Knight to F6 with check and now we
have access to the G4 Square so here uh
the best move is not to capture best
move is actually to just move the king
and allow Knight to D7 you have to give
up the exchange and uh suffer for the
rest of the game but uh you know
suffering against dubo isn't really what
what mless signed up for so he says it
either works so it doesn't G captures on
F6 was played and now Rook to E4 uh
going going for Rook to G4 check so how
can you how can you stop this well there
are a couple of moves you could try
there's a very tricky move it's a
disgusting Engine line but even with
that uh it doesn't work for example Pawn
to F5 you take away the G4 Square give
up the F5 pawn and now play C5 to allow
the queen uh control of the sixth Rank
and after Rook to G4 check King to h8 uh
you can play Queen to E5 which you could
also take the bishop that also works and
you're going to have um Queen and two
versus queen and two Rooks but the black
king side is completely busted you will
win this but there's an even cleaner way
of Queen to E5 check only move F6 and
now uh well only reasonable move F6 uh
and now after Queen to H5 threatening
mate in one you will have to play F5 to
defend the H6 pawn and now Rook to G6
attacks the queen and the H6 Pawn you
will have to give up the queen here and
after captures the only way to sort of
survive this is to play Rook to A6 uh
but still it's going to be a bishop and
Rook versus a queen not enough uh
material to to to fight duo with so
instead after Rook to E4 Bishop to D3
was played trying to get the bishop to
G6 to help out with the defense H but
now Rook to G4 with check Bishop to G6
and now Queen captures on H6 and it
seems like uh okay there's uh maybe a
way for black to defend this and black
finds the only only reasonable move and
that is Queen to B2 attacking the D
white Rook on A1 but now uh for the
final time uh feel free to pause the
video and try to find the the cleanest
way to win the game uh while I give you
a couple of
seconds so for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations unsporting
this idea and for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show it is Rook to H4
so du of sacrifices more material and
now there is no way to stop Queen to h8
Checkmate uh Queen captures on A1 check
was played but after King to G2 Bishop
to E E4 check was played uh Rook
captures on e4 and now Queen to D1
trying to defend the position but still
Rook to H4 threatening Checkmate Queen
to D5 with check we have Pawn to F3 and
he was in this position un move 31 that
mean resigned the game as there is
nothing more uh to be done here uh sorry
I forgot to update my interface here uh
to fix me's name there we go uh because
uh well now you you want to give a
couple of checks the queen to D2 check
is impossible the queen on H6 is
stopping that but after Queen to A2
check King H3 Queen to E6 with check
you're going to play G4 and now there
are no more moves so Queen to H6 will
just end the game or queen to H7 and I
mean what a what a fine find after this
uh Queen to B6 move like you want to
play Knight to F6 you you you really
want to play a du of had 7even minutes
and 15 seconds on the clock when he
decided to to play this move uh uh and
uh he spent a minute and 15 seconds
deciding on Bishop to F1 uh so yeah I
mean beautiful stuff you just you know
you realize that the bishop guarding the
G4 square is preventing you from this
spectacular attack and then you just
find the move Bishop to F1 I mean so so
elegant the Knight has no squares he
will take the Knight the bishop has to
defend the bishop moves from the defense
of G4 and then the attack just happens
and while mle could have U persevered a
bit longer by not not taking the Knight
playing that King to h8 line I mean
that's I guess against a player of dubo
strength it's the the same as a loss uh
so that's the game hope you guys enjoyed
it always always a pleasure to bring you
more du of games you know whenever he
plays everyone is will he will he
deliver and yes he he always delivers uh
so yeah once again really hope you guys
enjoyed it today no rapid action from me
but you have a nice rapid game from dubo
so hope you enjoyed that I would like to
thank Samuel Kan Gard hlan Jeremy antios
Carl and David gasparian for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot to really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing to check up on your
wonderful suggestions and whatever else
happens in the Chess World uh so thank
you all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your
day